welcome back okay we're talking about
Koopman operator theory finding
coordinate transformations that map my
strongly nonlinear dynamics into a
coordinate system where the dynamics
appear linear in time we've talked about
the overarching goal some of the
numerical methods used to approximate
Koopman operator theory and this
fundamental challenge of representing
these eigenfunctions which are these
good i ghen measurements where the
dynamics look linear but now i want to
talk about the applications okay so this
is this Koopman spectral analysis i want
to talk about the application to control
theory okay so one of the the core kind
of challenges in this dynamical system
is optimal non-linear control and
estimation and this is one of the huge
promises of Koopman theory is that
transforming into these these better
coordinate systems where things look
more linear will allow us to use
textbook methods and linear control
theory like linear quadratic regulator
x' and common filters for for strongly
nonlinear systems okay so simple
one-line commands in MATLAB
if I had the right coordinate system
might allow me to regulate and estimate
even these strongly nonlinear systems so
that's like a holy grail of nonlinear
control theory is finding these
coordinate transformations so that's an
upfront cost but then everything
downstream in the control and estimation
becomes very very simple okay and if you
want to know what you can do with linear
control just go check out the control
bootcamp where you can see kind of how
easy it is to do lqr and calman filter
control and estimation okay so that's
the goal we're going to talk about now
is how to use Koopman for non-linear
control I want to point out this is a
vast and rapidly growing field I'm gonna
give you kind of a little window into
what we're doing in my group and with my
collaborators on nonlinear control and
estimation with Koopman but there are
lots of teams across the world that are
doing this and and so it's a huge field
very very important because there's so
much potential once you find these
coordinates of doing optimal control
with simple techniques okay so this is
an example I've talked about before in a
lot more depth where you have this this
nonlinear system but if you found these
good measurement core
these non-linear measurements you can
get a linear dynamical system
representation of these dynamics okay if
you had that same system with an
actuator with some control input u that
affects the second state x2 it turns out
that in these Koopman coordinates you
get a linear control system y dot equals
a y plus bu and that linear dynamical
system encodes this non-linear control
problem so if you have a linear system
with an a matrix and a b matrix you can
write down a linear a quadratic cost
function that penalize --is so you're
trying to stabilize the system rapidly
you want X to go to the origin as fast
as possible and you want the control
expenditure you to be as small as
possible so you're balancing these two
and this cost function and in one line
in MATLAB you can essentially cook up
this linear quadratic regulator
controller that minimizes this cost
function given these dynamics and in the
lqr controller you'll get three terms
out because you have three states so
there will be three terms the first two
are the gains that you feed back the
direct measurements x1 and x2
but the third lqr control gain is
actually this nonlinear control term in
terms of y3 so essentially once you find
these coordinates you write down your
one-line MATLAB code to get an lqr
controller and what you get out in your
original coordinates is an optimal
nonlinear control law so that's awesome
we've been wanting optimal non-linear
control for a long time and what you do
is if you apply this a nonlinear control
law you can see this cost function here
you're trying to make the cost as small
as possible
if I just naively linear as my system
about the origin which is what we
traditionally do and I do lqr I get a
pretty high cost of control but if I use
this smarter Koopman linearization and I
apply this Koopman nonlinear controller
I get this much much more effective read
cost function that's about three times
less expensive to control the system so
it's three times more effective in this
cost function using this non-linear
control law and this i got this with a
one-line matlab command so it's really
cool
okay so that's what we want to do and
essentially this Koopman controller
understands these intrinsic dynamics the
slow manifold and instead of fighting
that it's taking advantage of it okay so
this is what we want to do and the
pipeline the way I I think of this
pipeline we want to take our data we
want to write down our dynamical system
maybe we don't know the equations so we
want to discover these using DM de D and
D Cindy whatever your favorite method we
want to find these good Koopman
embedding coordinates these good Y
coordinates are nonlinear eigenfunction
measurements where my system looks
linear and then we want to do Koopman
operator control to get nonlinear
optimal control so that's the pipeline
we've been developing for years now this
is kind of one of the big goals is even
if you don't know your system or these
good measurements can I mine that from
data and do optimal nonlinear control
and I think we made some some really
cool progress we in you know my group
and collaborators but also more broadly
in the community okay so this is work
with Oracle hyzer Nathan cuts and myself
so all of this stuff on Koopman control
is with with Nathan and Eric has done
great work showing that you can
essentially discover these Koopman
eigenfunctions these good
representations purely from data for
unknown systems and then you can use
those good coordinates to develop
optimal nonlinear control laws that are
super effective okay so this is the
pipeline you have data from some unknown
system you discover your eigenfunctions
you incorporate the effect of control
and then you design a control lot to
feedback okay and this is based on that
basic generator equation before that
that kind of PDE for Koopman
eigenfunctions so now we're gonna take D
DT of feed we still get grad fee times X
dot but now X dot is not just an
autonomous dynamical system it has a
control input plus bu and you could make
this more general you can make it
non-linear control but i just want to
have this additive control because it's
easier to see what happens so i take the
chain rule and i get feed on equals grad
fee times f of X plus bu now if I didn't
have any control if I just had this
enforced system I would have these
eigenfunctions fee so grad Phi F is just
lambda fee remember these are eigen
functions of the unforced system and
then I have this correction term because
of my control input so this is really
really cool if I have I gain functions
if I can discover eigenfunctions of my
unforced system these lambda these fee
functions for my unforced system then
even when I write down for my control
system the fee dynamics are still linear
in the state fee and there's this non
linear in the state control input grad
fee X dot bu so the dynamics are still
linear but now I had this state
dependent actuation grad fee X dot B so
that basically means that my actuator
has different effectiveness and
different characteristics depending on
where I am in the state space but the
dynamics and my eigenfunction
coordinates remains linear and that's
the key thing here and that's what Erika
is using to design these these linear
control laws using simple methods to
stabilize these strongly nonlinear
systems okay very cool idea and that's
that's this expansion here and we've
seen before that we can find these fee
functions these eigenfunctions of the
unforced system using this kind of
sparse identification we find the fewest
terms and a library to give fee so we
can discover these from data we write
them down with this extra controller
here and what Erika showed is that you
can essentially use the same quadratic
cost function the same kind of lqr cost
function but now we can represent our
cost in terms of these eigen functions
directly so instead of trying to move
the state X to the origin or to some
reference value or directly going to
steer the eigenfunctions themselves this
is a little bit of a weird idea but I
think it's very natural for lots of
physical systems so for example if I
have an inverted pendulum on a cart
maybe I want to stabilize it in the up
position and I can write that up
position as theta equals pi and theta
dot equals zero something like that but
it turns out for for that system which
is conservative Hamiltonian system the
total conserved energy is a Koopman
function fee and so instead of
controlling the state to be up maybe I
want to control the Hamiltonian energy
to be exactly equal to the energy of the
up position and so that's the kind of
control that we're able to do now is
we're able to directly steer the energy
to higher or lower values or steer the
angular momentum to higher or lower
values in an optimal way so this is an
optimal way of pumping energy into the
system to rip to raise the pendulum or
to add angular momentum to a system and
you can essentially solve this control
problem this control optimization if
this was just a vector bu I could use a
riccati equation but now because this is
a state dependent actuation vector we
use a state dependent riccati equation
sulfur and s D re a state dependent
riccati equation but those are still
pretty standard optimization techniques
that you can do in MATLAB or other other
software environments to find the
optimal solution the optimal control as
a function of your state fee given that
you have a state dependent actuation
okay so that's what we did in this
archived paper and we've applied it to a
lot of Hamiltonian systems but it also
generalizes for other eigenfunctions
okay so lots of Hamiltonian systems have
this conserved energy as an
eigenfunction so here we have a quartic
potential well the Duffing oscillator
and the pendulum and in each of these
cases purely from measurement data Erika
was able to extract these Koopman
eigenfunctions these lightly damped or
not damped at all kind of zero
eigenvalue conserve energy and then she
was able to design an optimal non-linear
control law in those coordinates to
change the energy value so either to go
from the inside of a well from the
inside of well up or down or to you know
stabilize the pendulum in different
energy configurations okay she's also
applied this to systems where there's
multiple potential wells so this is
called well hopping or well switching
where what you can do is essentially
switch your control law so I'm going to
do an optimal control law to try to get
me to this energy
value and then I'm gonna push myself
over the hill and use another optimal
Koopman controller to bring my energy
down to this energy value okay so it's
this two-step procedure where you can
jump from one well to the next in an
optimal nonlinear way this is a problem
that I've been interested in for most of
my career because this is actually very
very relevant for space mission design
so each planet and moon is a potential
energy well so this might be Earth's
potential well and this might be
Jupiter's potential well and all of this
is living in the sun's potential well
which is much much larger and so if you
want to do energy efficient space
mission designs maybe I want to go
explore the different moons of Jupiter
and when I get bored with this moon I
want to jump to the next moon and then
maybe that's really interesting so I
stay there for longer and then I jump to
a third moon you have to be able to do
this energy efficient optimal non-linear
control to jump between these multiple
wells so that's the project that lots of
people have been working on for a long
time my undergrad advisor Jerry Marsden
was working on this back then it was
called the Jupiter icy moon orbiter and
it's been an inspiration in dynamical
systems and control for for a long time
so we were really pleased when this
data-driven control with Koopman could
derive these control laws to get you
into these different favorable
configurations really cool and then as
the last example this is a higher
dimensional problem this is a double
gyre model which models ocean mixing so
you have these kind of big
counter-rotating vortices and you can
have drifter particles like you know
maybe there's a buoy in the ocean that's
drifting around in this big vortex basin
and what Erika was able to do is using
this optimal Koopman control so finding
these good coordinates for this system
and then developing controllers in those
coordinates you can essentially
stabilize swarm behaviors to get this
kind of coordinated control in this
system very very cool stuff okay so you
can read about this it's an archive
paper I really like this paper a lot
it's kind of a fun idea where you find a
good coordinate system and you do
control in that coordinate system
now I want to point out this is
absolutely not in isolation there are
tons of methods developing Koopman based
control and estimation this is only a
small handful and if you watch this
video in a year I'm guessing there will
be twice as many at least okay so this
is a rapidly developing field very high
potential reward for finding these good
coordinate systems for control there's
so I'll just give you a very brief
sketch of some of the big ones okay
Amit cerana has done great work with
Koopman based calman filters so non
linear estimation problems using Koopman
based Kalman filters very very
impressive performance demonstrations
Mila and kurta and Igor message have
done great work applying model
predictive control to EDM D models that
essentially take into account the
nonlinear evolution and use model
predictive control for very very
effective control design so this is
great work also applied to power grid
stabilization so really cool stuff there
there's also great work looking at
switching systems so Sebastian pates and
collaborators have looked at can I
develop different Koopman models for
different control inputs maybe my
control is set to zero I build a Koopman
model there my control is set to one I
build a Koopman model there and they use
model predictive control and other
techniques to optimally switch between
these these autonomous Koopman dynamical
systems for some high-level control
objective okay lots and lots and lots of
great stuff I encourage you to kind of
dive into this it's a rich field very
very important to be able to find these
non-linear coordinates that makes your
control problem more amenable to linear
analysis okay so in the next few
lectures we'll also talk about these
extra hard to represent systems and how
we find eigenfunctions there okay thank
you